what is uh is there any plan like soon
to get any any of your brothers
unreleased [ __ ] out yeah i'm supposed to
we're supposed to be doing some [ __ ] in
the summer
but like if i can't get most of them
songs [ __ ] he don't need features i i
like his [ __ ] better without features
like you know what i'm saying yeah
because i mean
is it hard i mean obviously with him not
being here i'm sure he had some big
features he was sitting on now to see
the features it's more like on [ __ ]
just like all right let's go clear just
because you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] just guys on major labels
you know i don't know that's
weird saying we're like oh i mean i
guess you probably can't say who are
some of the unreleased features oh he
got a gang [ __ ] he got like he got
features with everybody he probably got
like the songs that i got he got like a
playboy cardi verse he got like those
zuma verbs quite well
money man i swear
uh
um i think
[ __ ] a peasy verse
we got a shy grizzy version i'm sure all
the independent stuff will be easy to
clear yeah for sure oh ozuna though
yeah for sure that's crazy that's tg
you gotta um
it's a bunch of the plug versus uh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] he got a little bit everything
right you know